Grazie
Questo applauso non è per me
è per il fatto che siamo ancora qui
nonostante tutto ci siamo
e ci resteremo
e ci torneremo
non sapete come mi sento in colpa
a togliermi questa che voi siete obbligati a tenerla
però così è
allora noi
voi avete sentito parlare di sogni
per giorni e giorni
e anche adesso parleremo di sogni
nel senso proprio letterale del termine
cioè proprio i sogni che si sognano la notte
salvo che parleremo
di come si sognava nel Medioevo
e soprattutto
di come il sogno veniva usato
dagli scrittori
e dai poeti del Medioevo
quindi parleremo essenzialmente
di letteratura però
lasciatemi fare un po' di premessa
perché credo che sia necessaria
cosa voleva dire sognare nel Medioevo
cosa voleva dire per loro sognare
e come sognavano
io direi questo
che da un lato
sognavano esattamente come noi
perché i meccanismi del sogno
la logica
demenziale del sogno
vengono da dentro di noi
uscivano fuori da loro
dal loro inconscio
anche se loro non sapevano
di avere un inconscio
esattamente come
vengono fuori dal nostro
però poi i sogni
sono popolati
delle cose che abitano
la nostra vita quotidiana
e in questo senso
alle persone del Medioevo
capitava di sognare cose diverse
da quelle che sogniamo noi
vi faccio un primo esempio
di un sogno fatto nel Medioevo
qui non siamo in letteratura
e si tratta di un sogno autentico
tramandato da un cronista
è un sogno del re di Francia
Carlo VI
re di Francia
alla fine del 300
Carlo VI
re di Francia
sogna
che gli hanno regalato
un falcone da caccia
un falcone meraviglioso
mai visto uno così
tenete conto che il falcone
è un oggetto preziosissimo
ed è davvero un regalo da re
perché il falcone
è difficilissimo
procurarselo
allevarlo
mantenerlo
quindi è veramente
un regalo da re
il re sogna
che gli hanno regalato
questo falcone
immediatamente
esce a caccia
per provarlo
e il falcone
vola via
e gli scappa
e il re dietro
per non perderlo
e non riesce mai
a raggiungerlo
il falcone
vola sopra un bosco
il re si trova
in questo bosco
non riesce
ad andare avanti
a cavallo
il cavallo
arranca
è costretto
a scendere
da cavallo
qui riconoscete
tutti un meccanismo
tipico anche
dei nostri sogni
no?
devi fare qualcosa
e non riesci
a farlo
io sogno
regolarmente
che devo prendere
il treno
che è già tardi
e non faccio
già più in tempo
andare alla stazione
non ho ancora
fatto i bagagli
e devo riempire
queste valigie
e non si riesce
mai a riempirle
a chiuderle
allo stesso modo
il re sogna
che non si riesce
mai andare avanti
dietro questo falcone
e poi sbuca
in una radura
e il falcone
è là
ma è lontano
e spunta
un cervo
e questo cervo
ha le ali
e il re
inforca
il cervo
sale a cavallo
sul cervo
e il cervo
decolla
e a cavallo
del cervo
volante
il re
raggiunge
il suo falcone
e lì si sveglia
ed è così
eccitato
così emozionato
da questo sogno
che comincia
a raccontarlo
a tutti
e per un bel po'
non riesce a smettere
di pensare
a questo sogno
e lo racconta
a tutti quelli
che ci sono lì
intorno a lui
fra gli altri
lo racconta
al cronista
Jean Froassart
che è l'autore
di una grande cronaca
della vita di corte
in Francia
in Inghilterra
al tempo della guerra
dei cent'anni
e Froassart
lo ha raccontato
a noi
quindi
quindi da un lato
certi meccanismi
del sogno
sono ben riconoscibili
devi raggiungere
devi arrivarci
e non ci riesci mai
però di solito
noi non sogniamo
falconi
e neanche cervi
a lati o meno
e invece queste cose
fanno parte
della vita quotidiana
di un re
o di un nobile
del medioevo
e quindi sogna quello
i meccanismi
come vi dicevo
sono molto simili
ai nostri
e ogni tanto
si ritrovano
quando un autore
del medioevo
racconta un sogno
specialmente
quando non è
un sogno
costruito
con uno scopo
letterario
ma quando è proprio
qualcuno
che racconta
un sogno
che ha fatto lui
davvero
in modo diciamo così
ingenuo
c'è un sogno
raccontato
dal signor
di Joanneville
che è un nobile
francese
del 200
è un gran signore
molto legato
al re
Luigi IX
il santo
ha un rapporto
molto stretto
è un suo dipendente
ma ha un rapporto
di amicizia
con il re
e Joanneville
racconta
un sogno
in cui è molto facile
individuare
come dire
una tipologia
di sogno
che facciamo
anche noi
oh
preciso
Joanneville
ha un rapporto
estremamente disteso
con il re
lo sogna poi
dopo che il re
è morto
molti anni dopo
ma finché il re
era vivo
Joanneville
che era più giovane
di lui
aveva però
con lui
un rapporto
estremamente disteso
come poteva succedere
nel medioevo
quando non c'erano
molte costrizioni
di etichetta
di comportamento
e i rapporti umani
erano più diretti
e più immediati
di quelli che saranno
in altre epoche
provo a darvi un esempio
di quello che voglio dire
Joanneville
è continuamente
al fianco del re
che è un santo
che il re è un santo
lo sanno tutti
non è sempre facile
stare insieme a un santo
perché può capitare
che il santo
alla vigilia
del venerdì santo
si prepara
a lavare i piedi
a dodici poveri
e quel venerdì santo
al re Luigi
viene in mente
di dire a Joanneville
Sire di Joanneville
fareste bene anche voi
a lavare i piedi
ai poveri
è una cosa
che fa molto bene
all'anima
e Joanneville risponde
Sire
in fede mia
io i piedi
a quei fetenti
non li laverò mai
un'altra volta
al re santo
a cui piace scherzare
viene in mente
di porre un'alternativa
a Joanneville
porre un'alternativa
è un gioco di società
ti presento un problema
quale di queste due cose
preferiresti
e al re Luigi
viene in mente
di dire a Joanneville
Sire di Joanneville
vi voglio porre
un'alternativa
preferireste
essere lebroso
o aver commesso
un peccato mortale
e Joanneville risponde
Sire
ma io preferirei
aver commesso
cento peccati mortali
piuttosto che essere
lebroso
e si prende
la sgridata
della sua vita
naturalmente
allora
con questo re
con cui aveva
un rapporto
così intimo
ecco
questo re
poi muore
passano tanti anni
quando Joanneville
è vecchio
gli chiedono
di scrivere
quello che si ricorda
del santo re
perché è uno degli ultimi
che sono rimasti vivi
che lo conoscevano bene
e Joanneville
siamo ormai
all'inizio del 300
scrive
la vita
del santo re Luigi
e verso la fine
racconta
che una volta
lui l'ha sognato
il re
l'ha sognato
dice
mi sembrava
di vederlo
nella mia cappella
a Joanneville
nel castello
di Joanneville
e mi sembrava
che lui fosse
allegrissimo
contentissimo
e anch'io
ero molto contento
perché lo vedevo
nel mio castello
e gli dicevo
notate che lui
come spesso succede
quando i cronisti medievali
riportano un sogno
usa l'imperfetto
esattamente
come facciamo noi
c'era uno
e diceva
io facevo
nessuno sa bene
perché usiamo
l'imperfetto
per raccontare i sogni
ma funziona così
e lo facevano anche loro
e gli dicevo
sire
quando partirete di qui
vi ospiterò
in una mia casa
che si trova
in un mio villaggio
che si chiama
Chevillon
e lui mi rispondeva
ridendo
e mi diceva
sire di Joanneville
in fede mia
non ho mica voglia
di andar via
così presto
da qui
e lì
dice Joanneville
mi sono svegliato
perché vi dico
che è un sogno
molto simile
ai sogni
che facciamo
certe volte noi
almeno a me capita
ma credo a tutti
un sogno di cui
ti ricordi pochissimo
ti ricordi che c'era
una persona
che spesso è uno
che è già morto
o che comunque
non dovrebbe essere lì
e tutto quello
che ti ricordi
sono due battute
una frase
magari una frase
completamente idiota
che non c'entra niente
perché mai
a Joanneville
nel sogno
viene da dire
quando andrete via
da qui
vi ospiterò
in una mia casa
non significa nulla
oppure significa
qualcosa
come quando il re dice
ma io non voglio
andarmene da qui
Joanneville
ovviamente
cosa pensa
pensa
il re
è venuto a trovarmi
il re che è morto
da tanto tempo
è venuto a trovarmi
e vuol dire
vuol dire
che ha piacere
di abitare con me
il risultato
è che Joanneville
a sue spese
fa costruire
un altare
nella cappella
del suo castello
dedicato
a San Luigi
perché il re
è venuto in sogno
a dirgli che voleva stare
da lui
però rimane il fatto
che il meccanismo
del sogno
è esattamente
quel tipo di meccanismo
di un brevissimo
scambio di frasi
che ritroviamo
molto spesso
quando qualcuno
oggi racconta
un suo sogno
combinazione
pochi giorni fa
mentre preparavo
questa lezione
è uscita
sui giornali
un'intervista
di Oliver Stone
il regista
americano
Oliver Stone
raccontava
che lui
aveva un pessimo
rapporto
con suo padre
finché suo padre
era vivo
e poi dice
una notte
ho sognato
mio padre
si è seduto
sul mio letto
e mi ha detto
con il suo ghigno
luciferino
sei l'ultima persona
che pensavo
potesse sfondare
stronzetto
schizzato
allora
al di là
del contesto
di nuovo
compare uno
che è morto
cosa ci fa lì
però è lì
in casa mia
in camera mia
e io mi sveglio
ricordandomi una frase
quindi il meccanismo
come si vede
è lo stesso
però
l'uso
che poi noi
facciamo
di questi sogni
il senso
che noi diamo
a questi sogni
è diverso
rispetto a quello
che faceva
la gente
del medioevo
Oliver Stone
dopo questo sogno
cosa fa
si mette a ragionare
sul proprio
rapporto
freudiano
con il padre
che ha sempre avuto
un cattivo rapporto
col padre
e così via
invece
Juanville
pensa che il re
gli abbia mandato
un messaggio
dall'altro mondo
e proprio questo
è il punto
noi che abbiamo letto
il dottor Freud
pensiamo
che i sogni
stavo per dire
sappiamo
sì
in Alimassima
lo sappiamo
però è sempre meglio
essere modesti
noi pensiamo
che i sogni
vengano da dentro
di noi
i sogni
nascono
dentro di noi
e ci svelano
qualcosa
di chi siamo
qualcosa che non sapevamo
a livello conscio
o di qualcosa
che c'è successo
nelle prime fasi
della nostra vita
nel medioevo
ma come nell'antichità
loro non avevano mai letto
il dottor Freud
in compenso
nel medioevo
avevano letto
un sacco di libri
scritti nell'antichità
che spiegavano
come interpretare
i sogni
e per loro
erano qualcosa
che non nasce
dentro di noi
ma che viene
da fuori
il problema
poi è capire
da dove viene
già gli antichi
si ponevano il problema
il sogno
è una cosa ambigua
me l'hanno mandato
gli dèi
che mi proteggono
o qualche potenza
malefica
che mi vuole
ingannare
è un presagio
del futuro
o invece
è una trappola
ecco
il medioevo cristiano
ha ereditato
questa cultura
e naturalmente
la interpreta
alla luce
dei suoi valori
il sogno
me lo manda Dio
è un avvertimento
è qualcosa
su cui devo
meditare
e forse
anche
è qualcosa
che mi permetterà
di sapere
cosa mi aspetta
o invece
è il diavolo
che me l'ha mandato
e quindi
è un inganno
un'illusione
è tutto sbagliato
e non si sa
oh naturalmente
piccola premessa
che era meglio
se facevo prima
io dico
gli uomini
del medioevo
e uso uomini
per dire uomini
e donne
come si usa
nella nostra lingua
insomma ecco
gli esseri umani
vissuti allora
però ben inteso
le persone del medioevo
erano diversi
l'uno dall'altro
esattamente come noi
c'era di tutto
le persone erano
diversissime
l'una dall'altra
era pieno di gente
in gamba
e di imbecilli
era pieno di gente
per bene
e di furfanti
c'era gente
che pensava di tutto
credeva a tutto
le cose più diverse
e anche sui sogni
c'era gente
che ci credeva
e gente che non
ci credeva affatto
però a livello
intellettuale
quando ci si sforzava
di dare un senso
di trovare
un senso
ai sogni
l'idea era
probabilmente
li manda Dio
per avvertirci
di qualcosa
oppure sono i morti
che ci appaiono
perché vogliono
parlare con noi
proprio come
il buon re Luigi
voleva parlare
col sire di Joanville
per dirgli
che lui
nella sua cappella
si trovava tanto bene
ora
c'è un problema
però a questo punto
e il problema
è questo
che se tu appartieni
a una cultura
come appartenevano
questi intellettuali
del medioevo
a una cultura
per cui i sogni
in linea di massima
hanno un significato
trasmettono
un messaggio
allora il rischio
è che quando poi
li racconti
e li trascrivi
e ci ragioni su
li razionalizzi
un po' troppo
io penso
che sia nell'esperienza
di tutti noi
che questo è un rischio
che corriamo anche noi
il fatto stesso
di raccontare
un sogno che hai fatto
ecco finisci
senza accorgertene
per mettere a posto
le cose
per far tornare
i conti
nel sogno vero
c'è una mancanza
di logica
straordinaria
che però
non si riesce
neanche a riferire
il fatto stesso
di metterlo su carta
lo tradisce
in qualche misura
quando gli autori
del medioevo
ma al pari
degli antichi
quando gli autori
del medioevo
raccontano un sogno
il guaio
è che loro pensano
che quel sogno
ha un significato
e hanno già capito
cosa significa
e quindi
lo aggiustano
i sogni
che si trovano
nei libri medievali
rischiano sempre
di essere
un po' troppo
coerenti
per il nostro gusto
c'è un po' troppa
logica
anche quando
sembra che
l'autore parli
di un sogno vero
non di un sogno
inventato
per dimostrare
qualcosa
ecco
un sogno vero
però
tornano troppo
bene i conti
vi faccio
un altro esempio
siamo nell'undicesimo
secolo
in Francia
un cronista
che si chiama
Rodolfo il Glabro
un monaco
cluniacense
scrive una grande
cronaca
in cui racconta
mille episodi
episodi importanti
ed episodi
minimi
a un certo punto
Rodolfo il Glabro
racconta
è successo questo
c'era un contadino
che si chiamava
Leutardo
e questo contadino
un giorno
mentre lavorava
nei campi
gli è preso
l'abbiocco
ha fatto un sonnellino
nel campo
e mentre dormiva
ha sognato
che uno sciame
di api
gli entrava
nel corpo
entrava da sotto
dall'orifizio posteriore
gli entrava nel corpo
e ronzava
dentro di lui
e queste api
gli parlavano
e lui non riusciva
a capire
cosa gli dicevano
e poi alla fine
sono uscite
tutte dalla bocca
e Leutardo
si è svegliato
e quando si è svegliato
non era più lui
è andato a casa
e ha divorziato
dalla moglie
perché d'ora in poi
voleva vivere
in castità
ed è andato in chiesa
e ha tirato giù
il crocifisso
della parrocchia
e l'ha calpestato
l'ha spezzato
perché i preti
raccontano solo bugie
e lui sapeva la verità
e lui si è messo
a predicare
e predicava
alla gente
e la brava gente
gli andava dietro
e Leutardo
predicava
tante cose
per esempio
che non bisogna
pagare le decime
al clero
finché il vescovo
informato di quello
che succedeva
ha convocato
Leutardo
l'ha interrogato
si è convinto
che non era un profeta
ma era un povero pazzo
ha spiegato al popolo
che quello lì
era un pazzo
e che non bisognava
starlo a sentire
la gente
si è fatta convincere
dal vescovo
tutti i seguaci
di Leutardo
l'hanno abbandonato
Leutardo
fuori di sé
dalla rabbia
si è buttato
in un pozzo
si è suicidato
tenete conto
che il suicidio
dal punto di vista
di un monaco
dell'undicesimo secolo
è il peggiore
dei peccati
perché è il peccato
della disperazione
e quando non credi
più
che potresti salvarti
che Dio potrebbe salvarti
no?
ecco
allora
allora qual è il punto?
che è bellissimo
il sogno
dello sciame di api
che ti entra nel corpo
dall'orifizio sbagliato
e poi esce dalla bocca
che bello
se fosse un sogno vero
però è anche talmente
come dire
telefonato
perché torna tutto
gli è uscito dalla bocca
e lui poi si è messo
a predicare
e gli uscivano
dalla bocca
parole di miele
ecco
e tutta la gente
lo stava a sentire
ma quelle parole
erano di origine
diabolica
come dimostra
appunto
l'orifizio
da cui erano
entrate
e quindi
come fa uno
a dire
magari c'è qualcosa
di vero
ecco
torna troppo
per lo scopo
diciamo
che deve avere
per lo scopo educativo
questo
questo episodio
se dalle cronache
passiamo
alla letteratura
di invenzione
che è poi
il tema principale
di cui vorrei trattare
ecco
vediamo che
per gli autori medievali
come anche per quelli
di altre epoche
sia chiaro
per gli autori medievali
il sogno
è una grande risorsa
è qualcosa
che si può usare
in molti modi
nella propria opera
letteraria
e lo si può usare
innanzitutto
per trasmettere
visto che i sogni
hanno un significato
ecco
secondo loro
allora lo si può usare
per trasmettere
un messaggio
per parafrasare
un'idea
un'allegoria
sapete
perché a scuola
ce l'hanno spiegato
in tutti i modi
e hanno cercato
di farcelo piacere
in tutti i modi
che nella mentalità
dei letterati medievali
l'allegoria
è qualche cosa
di fantastico
a loro piace molto
in genere
non è nel nostro gusto
ma il sogno
è un modo
per rafforzare
ulteriormente
l'allegoria
cioè
trasmettere
un messaggio
attraverso
una storia
apparentemente
diversa
è più facile
se faccio
un esempio
tanti anni fa
io qui a Sarzana
ho fatto una conferenza
su una scrittrice
medievale
che si chiama
Christine de Pisan
è una scrittrice
francese
vissuta a cavallo
fra tre e quattrocento
che è straordinaria
come figura
non tanto
per la sua bravura
quanto perché
non la prima donna
scrittrice
ce ne erano già state altre
di donne che scrivevano
ma Christine
è la prima donna
che scrive
per denaro
e che si mantiene
scrivendo
dei libri
e si mantiene
scrivendo dei libri
perché Christine
è una ragazza
della buona società
figlia di un medico
di corte
siamo in Francia
alla corte
del re di Francia
anche se lei
è di origini italiane
in realtà
ha sposato
un segretario
del re
quindi siamo
in un ambiente sociale
molto vicino
alla corte
poi però
il marito
è morto
e quando il marito
Christine
si è trovata
da sola
a dover
come dire
rimboccarsi
le maniche
e cercare
di capire qualcosa
degli affari
di famiglia
dei fondi
che suo marito
aveva investito
lei non sapeva niente
doveva degli stipendi
arretrati
da riscuotere
ha dovuto
prendere in mano
lei la famiglia
e lì si è accorta
che siccome
lei da tempo
scriveva
scriveva poesie
d'amore
ma scriveva anche
trattati
morali
e si è accorta
che queste cose
piacevano
e che il re
i principi
erano disposti
a pagare
a farle
dei bei regali
in cambio
della dedica
di queste sue opere
e Christine de Pizan
è diventata
una scrittrice
professionale
che sfornava
un libro
dopo l'altro
ottenendo
dalla corte
bei regali
insonanti
monete d'oro
per tutti questi libri
ora Christine
stiamo parlando
dei sogni
giusto?
Christine a un certo punto
in una sua opera
prova a raccontare
cosa ha voluto dire
per lei
perdere suo marito
ed essere costretta
lei una donna
a prendere in mano
la famiglia
lo racconta
con un'allegoria
secondo il loro gusto
a loro piace
questo
lei racconta
che si trovava
imbarcata su una nave
e che questa nave
è finita in preda
ai flutti
e che la tempesta
ha trascinato in mare
il capitano
della nave
con questo
lei vuole raccontare
appunto
la morte
di suo marito
la tempesta
ha trascinato in mare
il capitano
la nave
andava alla deriva
senza il suo bravo
nocchiero
e io ero disperata
dice Christine
piangevo
volevo buttarmi in mare
anch'io
mi hanno trattenuta
poi a forza di piangere
mi sono addormentata
e ho sognato
ho sognato
che mi appariva davanti
la fortuna
ora tenete conto
che la fortuna
per loro
nel medioevo
non era la stessa cosa
che è per noi
perché noi
al termine
al concetto di fortuna
diamo un significato
unicamente positivo
la fortuna
è quella che distribuisce
i gettoni d'oro
per loro invece
la fortuna
non è necessariamente
positiva
la fortuna
è quella forza
misteriosa
per cui a volte
la tua vita cambia
la fortuna
è il fatto
che nella tua vita
all'improvviso
può succedere qualcosa
che la rovescia
la ribalta
completamente
nel bene
ma anche nel male
questo è la fortuna
quindi una potenza
straordinaria
temibile anche
mi è apparsa
nel sogno
la fortuna
una donna
naturalmente
a loro piace
appunto
questa idea
dell'allegoria
trasformare un concetto
in un personaggio
e i loro personaggi
sono spessissimo
delle donne
la fortuna
ma anche
la ragione
la natura
la giustizia
noi nel nostro mondo
lo facciamo molto poco
lo facciamo un pochino
con la libertà
questa cosa
per cui a New York
c'è la statua
della libertà
che è appunto
una donna
solenne
e autorevole
nel medioevo
si immaginano
le cose
in questo modo
dunque mi è apparsa
la fortuna
nel mio sogno
dice Cristina
e ha cominciato
a toccarmi
e maneggiava
tutte le mie membra
e poi mi sono svegliata
e a risveglio
mi sono accorta
che avevo perduto
l'anello nuziale
e poi mi sono accorta
che ero cambiata
mi sono sentita
trasformata
dice Cristina
avevo le membra
più forti
e mi sentivo
molto più leggera
del solito
e la mia faccia
era cambiata
indurita
e la mia voce
era molto più grossa
e il corpo
era più forte
era più agile
io mi sono spaventata
e poi mi sono resa conto
che ero diventata
un uomo
notate questa cosa
Cristina prova
a immaginare
cosa vorrebbe dire
diventare un uomo
il messaggio allegorico
è chiaro
la fortuna
cioè la tragedia
che ha colpito la sua vita
la morte di suo marito
l'ha costretta
a prendere il posto
di suo marito
e lei vive questo
come dire
ho dovuto diventare
un uomo
ma nel momento
in cui prova
a raccontarlo
in concreto
a me ha colpito
moltissimo questa cosa
una donna del 300
che si immagina
come sarebbe
essere un uomo
e certe cose
sono ovvie
la voce più grossa
i lineamenti più duri
ma lei dice anche
mi son sentita
più leggera
questa donna
che è ancora giovane
ma è vedova
e ha già diversi figli
ha partorito
già diversi figli
vede gli uomini
sente la pesantezza
del suo corpo femminile
ha la sensazione
che gli uomini
sono più leggeri
e più agili
dice anche questo
dopodiché lei dice
io sono diventato
un uomo
e mi son messa io
a guidare la nave
che andava
allo sbando
io fui un vero uomo
capace di guidare navi
la fortuna
mi ha insegnato
questo mestiere
e poi dice
sono ancora oggi
un uomo
dopo tanti anni
ma mi piacerebbe
molto di più
essere una donna
come ero
quando mi sono sposata
ma visto che la fortuna
mi ha reso un altro
resterò un uomo
e mi terrò
attaccata alla fortuna
ora questo evidentemente
come dire
per carità
tutto è possibile
che abbia davvero
fatto un sogno simile
ma anche se non
l'avesse fatto
se lo poteva inventare
è una scrittrice
molto abile
e sa perfettamente
come un sogno
del genere
possa servire
per esprimere
in metafora
in allegoria
quello che le è successo
dunque il sogno
per uno scrittore
del medioevo
è una grande risorsa
è una risorsa
che serve
per trasmettere
dei messaggi
o che può servire
per inquadrare
un'intera opera
per fornire
un pretesto
una cornice
a un'intera opera
vi farò due esempi
di un'opera
che forse
non tutti conoscono
e di una
che invece
conoscete tutti
quella che forse
non tutti conoscono
si chiama
il Romain de la Rose
ed è
probabilmente
il più grande
bestseller
del medioevo
è un romanzo
scritto
nel duecento
in Francia
un romanzo
in versi
come si usava
e come piaceva
allora
è un romanzo
fiume
più di
ventimila versi
per capirci
più della divina
commedia
questo romanzo
interminabile
cominciato
da un autore
Guillaume Delory
concluso
dopo la morte
del primo
da un altro
autore
Jean Demain
che tutti
leggevano
nel medioevo
ci sono rimasti
trecento
manoscritti
di questo romanzo
sono rimaste
traduzioni
in tutte le lingue
medievali
c'è una traduzione
anche in italiano
antico
fatta nel duecento
già subito
è una traduzione
in forma di una collana
di sonetti
che si intitola
il fiore
e molti anni fa
uno dei nostri
grandi filologi
Gianfranco Contini
ha proposto
che forse
il fiore
la traduzione
del romando
la rosa
potrebbe essere
un'opera giovanile
di Dante
cosa racconta
il romando
la rosa
cos'è questa rosa
è il sesso
della donna
amata dal protagonista
e il romando
la rosa
racconta
come il protagonista
ha una gran voglia
di cogliere
questa rosa
e attraverso
innumerevoli avventure
e digressioni
di tutti i tipi
digressioni
nel corso
delle quali
si parla
di filosofia
di morale
di religione
di politica
del potere
del re
della società umana
di ogni sorta
di problemi
alla fine
se Dio vuole
il protagonista
coglie la rosa
e gli ultimi
tre o quattrocento
versi
descrivono
graficamente
che cosa vuol dire
quando finalmente
ci sei arrivato
cogliere
la rosa
ma tutto questo
l'autore
il primo
quello che ha inventato
l'idea del romanzo
Guillaume Delory
tutto questo
lui lo cala
nella cornice
di un sogno
dice tutto questo
è una cosa
che io ho sognato
quando ero giovane
e poi aggiunge
e questo dimostra
che i sogni
si avverano
perché poi
mi è successo davvero
sia chiaro
però
il modo in cui
ve lo racconto adesso
come ho colto
la rosa
ecco
quello è il modo
in cui
l'avevo sognato
i primi versi
di questo romanzo
fiume
attaccano
proprio frontalmente
il problema
del sogno
se i sogni
sono veri o no
se ci preannunciano
davvero il futuro
comincia così
il romanzo
della rosa
molta gente
dice che nei sogni
ci sono solo favole
e menzogne
e poi lui prosegue
dicendo
io invece credo
che i sogni
annunciano davvero
il bene
e il male
che sta per succedere
e quelli che dicono
che è da scemi
credere che i sogni
poi si avverano
vabbè
mi prendano pure per matto
perché a me invece
è capitato
notate bene
cosa vi dicevo prima
cosa pensa la gente
del medioevo
dei sogni
dipende
c'è chi è pronto
a giurare
che i sogni
preannunciano il futuro
e chi dice
ma che cretino
figurati
nemmeno pensarci
tutte frottole
e lui racconta
il sogno
che ha fatto
avevo vent'anni
l'età in cui
ci si innamora
ma lui dice
quando l'amore
fa pagare
il pedaggio
ai giovani
e ho fatto
un sogno
bellissimo
e poi
si è avverato
tutto
sognavo
che era una bella
mattina di primavera
che mi alzavo
dal letto
andavo in campagna
e mi veniva
voglia di andare
a raccogliere
una rosa
eccetera
se qualcuno
di voi
sta pensando
al nome della rosa
di Umberto Eco
fa bene
perché nel nome
della rosa
ben inteso
la rosa
è trattata
in tutt'altro modo
c'è il problema
del nome
della rosa
o dell'esistenza
diciamo
solo delle rose
concrete
oppure se esiste
da qualche parte
la rosa
come concetto
astratto
era un problema
che appassionava
gli intellettuali
del medioevo
e che nel romanzo
di Eco
appassiona
Guglielmo da Baskerville
il suo protagonista
detective
nonché
filosofo
e frate
domenicano
ecco
quindi diciamo
non si parla
del romano
della rosa
nel romanzo
di Eco
non si parla
da nessuna parte
che la rosa
nel romanzo
più famoso
di tutta la letteratura
medievale
vuol dire
il sesso
della donna
amata
dal protagonista
uno può leggere
il romanzo
di Eco
senza venirla
a sapere
questa cosa
ma Eco
lo sapeva
invece
perché lui
la letteratura
medievale
la conosceva
a menadito
e dunque
il romano
della rosa
è tutto
inserito
dentro la cornice
di un sogno
ma la stessa cosa
e qui veniamo
al secondo esempio
che invece
conoscete tutti
la stessa cosa
vale per la commedia
di Dante
il viaggio
all'inferno
è chiaramente
presentato
come un sogno
anche se
la cosa
è fatta
con astuzia
e può non
risultare
immediatamente
evidente
a una lettura
superficiale
ma in realtà
oggi
i critici
sono abbastanza
convinti
che Dante
ha voluto
dire
io questa
cosa
l'ho sognata
ha mandato
dei segnali
molto precisi
adesso ve li dico
nei primissimi
versi
dell'inferno
Dante
dice che lui
quando si è perso
nella selva oscura
stava morendo
di sonno
tant'era
pien di sonno
a quel punto
che la verace
via
abbandonai
alla fine
del penultimo
canto del paradiso
Beatrice
gli dice
Dante
facciamo presto
perché stai
per svegliarti
non lo dice
così letteralmente
ma perché
il tempo
fugge
che ti
assonna
qui
farem
punto
ci fermiamo
qui
perché il tempo
del tuo sonno
sta andando via
e scusate
se entro nel dettaglio
ma notate
la finezza
perché Dante
sarebbe contento
che noi lo notassimo
Dante
è di un'attenzione
strabiliante
nelle simmetrie
del suo poema
vi rileggo
questi pezzetti
tant'era
pien di sonno
a quel punto
che la verace
via
abbandonai
inizio
fine della commedia
ma perché
il tempo
fugge
che ti
assonna
qui
farem
punto
da un punto
all'altro
punto
Dante
ha inserito
i due indizi
del fatto
che l'intero
suo viaggio
è un sogno
e allora
viene in mente
naturalmente
che forse Dante
ha tradotto
il romano della rosa
se aveva ragione
Gianfranco Contini
il fiore
la traduzione italiana
del romano della rosa
l'ha fatta Dante
ma in realtà
Dante aveva in mente
anche altri riferimenti
della letteratura
medievale
conosceva una quantità
di testi
anche testi
che alla sua epoca
erano quasi
dimenticati
quasi sicuramente
Dante conosceva
la chanson de Roland
la prima
delle canzoni
di gesta
la chanson de Roland
è la canzone
in cui si canta
la morte del paladino
Orlando
a Roncisvalle
per capirci
e nella chanson de Roland
no meglio
ci arriviamo
dall'altro senso
ricordate tutti
perché tocca
studiarlo a scuola
che nel primo canto
dell'inferno
c'è una complicata
serie di immagini
in cui Dante
incontra
tre animali
la lonza
poi il leone
poi la lupa
con tutta la buona volontà
i critici
non sono mai riusciti
a spiegare esattamente
cosa vogliono dire
questi tre animali
e forse fra noi
possiamo anche dirci
una grande verità
cioè che Dante
all'inizio del suo poema
che stava ancora
prendendo confidenza
con questa forma
con la terzina
e così via
non è che
nell'immaginare
questi tre animali
crea chissà quale
grande opera poetica
ecco
non è chissà quale
capolavoro
questa idea
della lonza
e del leone
e della lupa
che gli vengono incontro
poi nel resto
della commedia
non se ne parla più
per nulla
ma c'è qualcosa
di molto simile
nella chanson
de Roland
perché nella chanson
Carlo Magno
in sonno
viene avvertito
della tragedia
che sta per accadere
a Roncisvalle
perché gli appaiono
in sogno
tre belve
tre animali
che uno dopo l'altro
gli si parano davanti
e sono prima
un orso
e poi un leopardo
e poi un veltro
altro termine
dantesco
fra l'altro
ecco
la grande maggioranza
dei critici
oggi sarebbe disposta
a dire
sì
Dante
quando ha questa idea
di tre animali
che lo incontrano
all'inizio
del suo sogno
si sta ricordando
dei tre animali
che hanno incontrato
Carlo Magno
nel sogno
della chanson
de Roland
dopodiché
gli studiosi di Dante
si dividono
fra due alternative
e cioè
va bene
Dante
presenta la commedia
come un sogno
lo fa
prima alternativa
perché è una costruzione
letteraria
che ha deciso
di fare
lui si è seduto
a tavolino
si è detto
allora come comincio
come l'ha imposto
questa cosa
beh
facciamo come
nel romano della rosa
facciamo che è un sogno
oppure
altra alternativa
Dante sognava davvero
a Dante è successo
davvero
di sognare
che andava
all'altro mondo
ovviamente
non tutto
non tutti i dettagli
che poi racconta
nella commedia
ma davvero
faceva dei sogni
del genere
e davvero
questa ispirazione
che gli veniva
negli sogni
ha contribuito
a fargli decidere
di scrivere
la commedia
su questo
ci sono autori
che pensano
cose diametralmente
opposte
molti dicono
qualcosa di vero
ci deve essere
Dante sognava
davvero
probabilmente
ci sono autori
che si sono sforzati
a questo punto
di dire
ma non ci sono
delle malattie
che possono provocare
delle visioni
di quel genere
in sogno
e le hanno trovate
naturalmente
ci sono studiosi
i quali hanno proposto
che Dante
forse soffrisse
di epilessia
epilessia
che ti fa avere
appunto
delle crisi
degli svenimenti
e che nell'antichità
era conosciuta
come la malattia sacra
ieranosos
morbus sacer
perché si pensava
che le crisi epilettiche
le mandassero
gli dèi
proprio come i sogni
qualcun altro
dice no no
Dante soffriva
di narcolessia
che è ancora
un'altra malattia
che provoca
sonnolenza di urna
invincibile
eccolo lì
che racconta
entrava nel bosco
aveva un sale sonno
non stavo più in piedi
e allucinazioni
ora tutte queste cose
ve le racconto
perché è interessante
seguire questo dibattito
però una cosa
deve essere chiara
anche se a Dante
avessero detto
guarda caro
noi siamo in grado
di spiegare perfettamente
tu soffri di questa malattia
che ha questi sintomi
a Dante
non sarebbe interessato molto
lui avrebbe
comunque pensato
che i suoi sogni
le sue visioni
gli venivano
dall'alto
oggi diversi studiosi
non tutti
sia chiaro
i dantisti litigano
meravigliosamente
su tutto
e non c'è una cosa
su cui siamo tutti
d'accordo
ma molti studiosi
dicono Dante
in realtà
nella sua opera
da tanti indizi
del fatto che lui
a un certo punto
si è convinto
di essere un profeta
del fatto che davvero
dentro di lui
c'era una forza
sovrumana
che gli parlava
nei suoi sogni
e quindi
qualcuno dice
no no Dante
in sogno
è andato davvero
nell'aldilà
e si è convinto
che era un profeta
e che era incaricato
di raccontare
queste cose
ma nella letteratura
medievale
ci sono anche usi
molto più moderni
del sogno
un uso del sogno
come immagine
nella nostra
cultura moderna
è come dire
per alludere
al fatto
che la vita
è qualche cosa
di inafferrabile
di deludente
di fluttuante
alla fine
che non c'è niente
di vero
niente di solido
questo tema
nella letteratura europea
l'ha introdotto
alla grande Calderon
nel 600
con il suo dramma
la vita è il sogno
che toda la vita
è il sogno
i lo suegnos
suegnos
sono
che tutta la vita
è sogno
e i sogni
sono solo sogni
ecco il tema
della vanità
della vita
c'è un precedente
medievale
che è un poeta
tedesco
vissuto fra
XII e XIII secolo
molto più vecchio
di Dante
è un poeta tedesco
un minnesenger
come si dice
un cantore d'amore
è un poeta tedesco
che si chiama
Walter
von der Vogelweide
il quale
scrive
una canzone
per
sostanzialmente
per dire
quando si diventa vecchi
ti sembra che la tua vita
sia stata nulla
che sia svanita
che il mondo
non sia più quello di prima
non riconosci più niente
e ti chiedi
ma l'ho vissuto davvero
o solo ho sognato
a me come si sono dispersi
tutti i miei anni
l'ho sognata
me la son sognata
la mia vita
oppure è vera
e poi va avanti così
Walter
tutto quello che ho sempre
creduto che ci fosse
c'era davvero
oppure ho dormito
e non lo sapevo
ora mi sono svegliato
e non riconosco
cose che prima
mi erano familiari
come la mia mano
persone
paesi
che conosco
da quando ero bambino
sono diventati
estranei
proprio come se fosse
tutta una bugia
quelli che erano
i miei compagni di giochi
sono vecchi
e distanti
i campi sono abbandonati
i boschi tagliati
penso a tanti giorni felici
che mi sono spariti davanti
come un colpo dato nel mare
che per un attimo lo vedi
e poi non lo vedi più
non c'è più
ecco detto tutto questo
per dare appena un'idea
dei vari modi
in cui il sogno
può essere utilizzato
nella letteratura medievale
io in questa parte conclusiva
vorrei però concentrarmi
su una specifica
caratteristica
del sogno
tanto del sogno
nella realtà
di tutti noi
quanto del sogno
nella letteratura medievale
e cioè
la sua connessione
con la vita
amorosa
e sessuale
voi direte che già
nel romano della rosa
ce n'è la sufficienza
ma io qui voglio parlare
di qualcosa di più concreto
cioè dei veri e propri sogni
che traducono
delle emozioni
di tipo emotivo
amoroso
e sessuale
nella letteratura medievale
ci sono molti
esempi
di questo tema
declinati
su livelli diversi
diciamo
dal sublime
all'intermedio
al proprio
terra terra
al massimo
e io vi vorrei presentare
appunto
in questa parte conclusiva
tre esempi
esempio più alto
ce l'offre di nuovo Dante
nella vita nuova
ricordate
la vita nuova
è il romanzo
ormai i critici
non hanno problemi
a chiamarlo romanzo
in prosa
in cui Dante
racconta
il suo amore
per Beatrice
cioè per la bambina
di cui si è innamorato
quando lui aveva nove anni
e lei ne aveva otto
e che poi
gli è sempre rimasta
ficcata
nel cuore
nella testa
Dante racconta
nella vita nuova
come durante l'adolescenza
lui continuava
a essere follemente
innamorato di Beatrice
che aveva visto
una volta in vita sua
e faceva di tutto
per riuscire a vederla ancora
ma non era mica
tanto facile
perché finché erano bambini
i bambini erano molto liberi
andavano in giro
seguivano i genitori
alle feste
si mescolavano
con gli adulti
ma quando una ragazza
era in età da marito
e cioè alla pubertà
e a quel punto
a Firenze
si usava
che non usciva
mica più tanto
di casa
i genitori
la tenevano in casa
Dante per anni
cerca di vedere Beatrice
e non ci riesce mai
poi finalmente
le incontra
sono passati nove anni
lui ha 18 anni
lei quasi
ma il bello
è che la loro posizione
nella società
ormai è completamente diversa
perché lui ha 18 anni
è ancora un adolescente
innamorato
senza arte ne parte
lei invece
che non ha ancora compiuto
18 anni
è una donna sposata
sposata da un po'
a un gran signore
e lui le incontra
per la strada
che andava in giro
con due altre signore
e io dice Dante
l'ho vista venire
bellissimo
perché Dante dice
mi è venuta una gran paura
cercavo di non farmi notare
e qui veramente
riconosciamo comunque
la psicologia
dell'adolescente
che in quella certa situazione
si fa prendere dal panico
Dante lo dice
a me mi ha preso il panico
non volevo farmi vedere
ma lei mi ha visto
e mi ha salutato
per nome
era la prima volta
che sentiva la sua voce
erano anni
che pensava a questa ragazza
è la prima volta
che lei lo saluta
a questo punto
Dante racconta
nella vita nuova
sono corso a casa
mi sono chiuso in camera
ho cominciato
a ripensare
a questo incontro
mi sembrava
di toccare il cielo
con un dito
e poi alla fine
mi sono addormentato
ed ecco che cosa sogna
Dante
secondo questo romanzo
anche se autobiografico
ma sempre un romanzo
che è
la vita nuova
dice Dante
mi sembrava di essere lì
nella mia camera
e di vedere
una nebbia rossa
che si spessiva
sempre di più
e in mezzo a questa nebbia
compariva una figura
la figura di un signore
di un gran signore
che sembrava molto allegro
e tuttavia
faceva paura
talmente era tremendo
vi stupirà
ma era
l'amore
descritto
esattamente
sulla base
dei ragionamenti
che si facevano
allora
tra l'altro
nell'ambiente
dei giovani letterati
a cui apparteneva Dante
i quali erano
molto interessati
all'amore
erano molto interessati
a capire cos'è
come funziona
ma ne avevano
anche una gran paura
perché percepivano
che l'amore
è una potenza
irrazionale
che ti fa fare
delle cose
contrarie
alla ragione
e per un intellettale
del medioevo
la ragione
era la cosa
più importante
che c'è
e seguire
degli impulsi
contrarie
alla ragione
era la cosa
più disumana
che si potesse fare
per cui
questi giovani letterati
erano lì
che si interrogavano
ma l'amore
bisogna seguirlo
o bisogna tenerlo
a distanza
bisogna combatterlo
domarlo
per questo
l'amore appare a Dante
nel suo sogno
come un signore
potentissimo
terribile
e mi parlava
diceva molte cose
io non capivo niente
poi alla fine
sono riuscito
ad afferrare una frase
io sono il tuo padrone
e poi mi sono accorto
che aveva qualcosa
in braccio
che aveva una figura
umana
nelle sue braccia
mi pare a vedere
una persona
dormire nuda
salvo che mi pareva
involta
in un drappo rosso
e poi si rende conto
che è Beatrice
in braccio
all'amore
che gli ha appena
dichiarato
io sono il tuo padrone
allora
allora anche qui
vedete
è chiaro che questo
è un sogno
costruito
da un letterato
che sta trasmettendo
dei significati
molto precisi
sarebbe tanto bello
sapere se quel giorno
Dante ha sognato
davvero qualcosa
su cui poi
ha costruito
questa immagine
perché se uno
volesse raccontarlo
in modo cinico
direbbe
questo diciottenne
innamorato perso
ha incontrato
dopo tanto tempo
la donna
di cui era innamorato
lei lo ha salutato
lui torna a casa
si chiude in camera
ci pensa
ci ripensa
si addormenta
e la sogna
nuda
ed è letteralmente così
dunque il nostro problema
in un caso come questo
è di capire
se ci sia dietro
una vera esperienza
onirica
dietro a questa costruzione
tutta letteraria
che Dante ha
montato
il secondo esempio
che volevo farvi
è tratto invece
da un romanzo
di Chrétien de Troyes
che è il primo
grande autore
di romanzi
cavallereschi
del genere
capite
la tavola rotonda
re Artù
l'Ancillotto
e Ginevra
Tristano e Isotta
questo genere
di cose qua
sono romanzi
di straordinaria
sottigliezza
questi di Chrétien de Troyes
vissuto anche lui
molto tempo prima
di Dante
uno di questi romanzi
si chiama
Cligès
è la storia
di un imperatore
di Bisanzio
l'usurpatore
Alice
tenete conto
che per il nostro pubblico
e il pubblico
dei nostri antenati
europei
occidentali
di quell'epoca
i bizantini
sono gentaglia
sono corrotti
effeminati
incapaci
perfidi
dunque
l'imperatore di Bisanzio
che è un usurpatore
vuole sposarsi
e fa venire
come moglie
la figlia
dell'imperatore
di Germania
che si chiama
Fenice
appena arrivata
a Costantinopoli
Fenice
è disgustata
dal marito
che è vecchio
e malvagio
e invece
si innamora
di sua nipote
che è giovane
e bello
e che si chiama
appunto
Cligès
però
le tocca
sposare il vecchio
lo sposa
e si prepara
alla prima notte
di nozze
e per la prima notte
riesce a dare
al marito
un sonnifero
in modo
da essere sicura
di non essere
toccata
e il romanziere
racconta
banchettano
tutta la sera
lei dà da bere
al marito
il vino
con la pozione
magica
il vino
piace molto
il marito
beve
beve tanto
dice Chrétien
che stanotte
dormirà
ubriaco
fradicio
ma non starà
tranquillo
anzi
la pozione
gli farà credere
di essere sveglio
mentre dorme
dopodiché
vanno a letto
è la prima notte
di nozze
dell'imperatore
vescovi e abati
benedicono
il letto nuziale
vanno a letto
e l'imperatore
come doveva
quella notte
è andato a letto
con sua moglie
cioè
come doveva
no
è una bugia
perché non l'ha toccata
né baciata
semplicemente
sono stati
nello stesso letto
capite che sto traducendo
e parafrasando
in italiano moderno
e in prosa
quello che in origine
è una cosa inversa
perché a loro piaceva così
però è una traduzione fedele
e sia chiaro
letterale
la ragazza
trema di paura
per l'ansia
che la pozione
non faccia effetto
ma in realtà
l'ha incantato così bene
che lui vuole solo dormire
e a quel punto
se la godrà
come si può godere
in sogno
e crederà
che sia tutto vero
lei per prudenza
si tiene a distanza
ma lui non può neanche avvicinarsi
si addormenta subito
dorme
e sogna
e crede
di essere sveglio
e si dà un grande affare
per coccolare la ragazza
e nel sogno
lei fa la difficile
e si difende
come fanno le vergini
e lui la prega
e la chiama
con molta dolcezza
mia dolce amica
e crede di tenerla
e non la tiene mica
e si gode il niente
perché non tocca niente
e non bacia niente
accarezza il niente
e parla al niente
non vede niente
e non stringe niente
e lotta col niente
la pozione era fatta bene
e lo tiene in ballo
tutta la notte
e gli fa fare
una gran fatica
e alla fine
è convinto
di aver conquistato
la fortezza
e se ne rallegra
ed è stanchissimo
e distrutto
e non ha fatto
niente del tutto
però qui a questo punto
vedete che c'è un problema
e cioè
ma allora sotto sotto
lo sapevano
che i sogni
vengono da dentro di noi
se non dall'inconscio
almeno dal desiderio
insoddisfatto
un poeta
che scrive
una storia del genere
non pensa certo
che quel sogno lì
gliel'ha mandato
il cielo
o il diavolo
gliel'ha mandato
la pozione
e il fatto
che è andato a letto
desiderando tanto
questo momento
e invece si è abbioccato
però allora appunto
se non a livello teorico
perché gli intellettualoni
che ragionavano
su queste cose
parlavano d'altro
ma se nella sensibilità
di un poeta
invece
può essere ben chiaro
che nei sogni
si traducono anche
certe nostre voglie
pulsioni
e desideri
insoddisfatti
ecco che allora
il sogno erotico
può avere
delle potenzialità
straordinarie
in letteratura
e questa è proprio
l'ultima cosa
con cui voglio
concludere
vorrei leggervi
in traduzione
una novella
ma in realtà
è un poemetto
francese
del XIII secolo
è un fablio
i fablio
sono appunto
dei poemetti
che però
hanno la stessa
caratteristica
delle novelle
per capirci
del boccaccio
è una storia breve
con dei protagonisti
tutta incentrata
su un aneddoto
una battuta
una barzelletta
uno scherzo
una situazione
particolare
e spesso
questi fablio
come del resto
le novelle
del boccaccio
hanno un contenuto
erotico
c'è un piccolo problema
che mentre il boccaccio
che vive
in una società
più tardi
rispetto ai fablio
francesi
e in una società
più snob
dal punto di vista
intellettuale
boccaccio è capace
di raccontare
come tutti sapete
le storie
più incredibili
senza mai usare
termini crudi
usa sempre
metafore
modi di dire
espressioni
ci gira intorno
non usa le parolacce
questi poeti francesi
dei fablio
usano le parolacce
cosa che io
non vorrei fare qui
perché non mi sento
così libero
come si sentivano
liberi loro
io ho la sensazione
che se io leggessi
questo fablio
mettendo le parolacce
al posto giusto
almeno qualcuno
arriccerebbe
di voi mi fido
ma insomma
non si sa mai
io direi
che siccome
questo fablio
racconta un sogno
qui si sta facendo
esegesi
della letteratura
medievale
è chiaro
io vi sto per
somministrare
la lettura integrale
in traduzione
di un poemetto
francese
del tredicesimo secolo
che ha
come al centro
l'idea di un sogno
in cui si sognano
degli oggetti
il cui nome
comincia per C
e contiene
delle Z
e io li chiamerò
i cosi
per capirci
il titolo
del poemetto
si può tradurre così
la voglia
dei cosi
sono contento
che apprezzate
il mio scrupolo
del resto ci sono
forse anche
dei minorenni
e poi siamo
anche trasmessi
voglio raccontarvi
una storia
che ho sentito
da qualche parte
ripeto
è una traduzione
mia
letterale
il più possibile
qua e là
un po' libera
ma insomma
ma non starò
a farla lunga
basta l'essenziale
è una storia
successa
a una coppia
marito e moglie
come si chiamavano
non lo so
ma erano due brave persone
tutte e due
e si volevano bene
dunque un giorno
questo bravo uomo
ha dovuto partire
per affari
ed è rimasto
via da casa
tre mesi
a trafficare
con le sue mercanzie
l'affare
gli è andato
benissimo
e lui
se n'è tornato
a casa
tutto allegro
ed è arrivato
un giovedì sera
la moglie
aveva già voglia
di vederlo
tornare a casa
e si capisce
che è stata contenta
quando l'ha visto arrivare
si sono dati un bacio
poi l'ha sistemato
ben comodo
vicino al fuoco
la legna
bruciava bene
senza fumo
e quando la cena
è stata pronta
hanno mangiato
lì
seduti su un cuscino
con il fuoco
che li illuminava
per cena
aveva preparato
due pietanze
carne e pesce
tutta roba buona
e vino buono
di Borgogna
e aveva messo
la tovaglia
di bucato
la moglie
serviva il marito
gli dava
i pezzi migliori
sapete
si mangia con le mani
naturalmente
c'è il piatto
di portata
con la cosa
già tagliata
bocconi
e ognuno
si prende
con regole
precisissime
di etichetta
e dopo essersi
lavati le mani
ognuno
si prende
il suo bocconcino
oppure
se vuoi
come dire
offrire il bocconcino
all'amato bene
gli offri
il bocconcino migliore
scelto apposta
per lui
e a ogni boccone
gli riempiva il bicchiere
perché lui
beveva volentieri
e intanto
che se la godevano
lì vicino al fuoco
lei pensava già
a godersela
anche dopo
a letto
solo che a forza
di riempirgli
il bicchiere
al marito
beh
l'ha fatto bere
troppo
quando se ne sono
andati a letto
lui si è addormentato
come un sasso
senza pensare
a nient'altro
vedete
l'autore di questo
fablio
probabilmente
aveva letto
cligess
e qui c'è
il rovesciamento
della situazione
in cligess
lei l'ha fatto
dormire apposta
qui lei non voleva
farlo dormire
però
è andata così
lei si che ci pensava
invece
si mette sotto
le coperte
ma non ha nessuna
voglia di dormire
anzi
gli va vicino
con una gran voglia
di coccole
e lui dorme
ma guarda
un po' pensa lei
che canaglia
e appena arrivato
a casa
è già dorme
mi secca proprio
sono tre mesi
che non lo tocco
ma che se ne vada
il diavolo
fa lei
delusa
però sta zitta
si gira
e si rigira
sotto le coperte
senza riuscire
a calmarsi
perché ha voglia
di fare l'amore
ma a svegliarlo
però si vergogna
ha paura
di far la figura
della puttana
e anzi
sta ben attenta
a non scuoterlo
insomma
alla fine
bene o male
si addormenta
tutta agitata
e di malumore
e mentre dorme
sogna
sogna di essere
alla fiera
ma una fiera
come non se ne sono
mai viste
sui banchi
e sotto i portici
e nelle botteghe
e in tutti gli angoli
non si vendono
pellicce
o telerie
o tessuti
come in tutte le fiere
e neanche coloranti
o spezie
insomma
nessuna merce
tranne una
cosi
e coglioni
di quelli
però
ce n'era
da perdere
la testa
tutti questi
plasi
vanno al collega
duecentesco
beninteso
tutte le botteghe
piene
su fino in soffitta
e continuamente
ne arrivavano
da tutte le parti
carri
e carretti
e facchini
carichi
di cosi
ma anche se
ce n'erano tanti
non erano mica gratis
anzi
erano tutti
in vendita
uno buono
costava 30 soldi
ma già per 20
ne prendevi uno carino
poi
c'erano i cosi
da povera gente
prendendone uno piccolo
ci si poteva divertire
già con 10 soldi
o anche meno
li vendevano
all'ingrosso
e al minuto
i più grossi
erano i migliori
e anche i più cari
beh
come dire
la signora
si guarda un po' intorno
e alla fine
ne vede uno
che le piace
lì su un banco
bello
grosso
e lungo
fa finta di niente
si appoggia lì vicino
se lo guarda
capite come funziona
il mercato
da noi nel medioevere
come adesso
nei paesi orientali
devi contrattare
non devi far capire
che l'articolo ti piace
ci pensi bene
poi cominci a contrattare
se lo guarda
per grosso
era grosso
nel buco
ci passava una ciliegia
a buttarla dentro
arrivava giù
senza fermarsi
fino in fondo
e i coglioni
erano larghi
come una pala
mai vista
una roba simile
beh la signora
si mette a contrattare
col padrone
ha meno di due marchi
fa quello
non lo venderei
neanche a mia sorella
non è mica
un coso da niente
è fabbricato in Lorena
lì li sanno fare
e quest'anno poi
i coglioni
vanno di moda
proprio così
lo prenda
fa il padrone
che fa un affare
senta
fa lei
è inutile farla
tanto lunga
le do 50 soldi
va bene
guardi che non so
dove le darebbero di più
50 soldi
più le tasse
fa il padrone
vabbè
più le tasse
fa la signora
ci perdo
fa lui
ma proprio perché
è lei
e vedrà
quando lo prova
mi saprà dire qualcosa
mi accenderà
una candela
vedrà
beh
l'affare è concluso
e come si usa
si battono il palmo
della mano
e la signora
che sognava
senza accorgersene
tira una sberla
al marito
che dormiva
così forte
che gli lascia
l'impronta
delle dita
sulla guancia
e si sveglia
con la mano
che le brucia
tanto forte
l'ha schiaffeggiato
e anche il marito
si sveglia di soprassalto
tutto spaventato
e lei ci rimane malissimo
quando si accorge
che è stato solo
un sogno
e lui le fa
ma di ma cosa
ti è saltato in mente
eri sveglia o dormivi
e lei gli fa
ma non l'ho fatto apposta
non volevo mica
picchiare te
beh fa lui
ma allora
cos'è che volevi fare
spiegami un po' bene
e lei
non so se ne aveva voglia
o no
ma comunque
alla fine
gli ha raccontato tutto
che ha sognato i cosi
e che se ne erano
di buoni e di cattivi
e che lei
si era comprato il suo
il più grosso di tutti
50 soldi più le tasse
e poi dice
dovevamo saldare l'affare
e ci siamo battuti
sulla mano
io credevo di battere
sulla palma del padrone
e invece ti ho picchiato
ma dormivo
non arrabbiarti per piacere
ti chiedo scusa
perdonami
vabbè fa lui
certo che ti perdono
dai figurati
poi la braccia stretta
e la bacia in bocca
e il coso
comincia a tirargli
perché a starle così addosso
lui si scalda
e lei gli piace parecchio
e lui glielo pianta in mano
e poi dopo un po' le fa
senti un po'
questo qui che tieni in mano
quanto lo avresti pagato
alla fiera?
e lei gli fa
guarda
di questi
potevi portarne anche
una cassa piena
che nessuno ti dava un soldo
anche
anche quelli da poveretti
uno solo ne valeva due
come il tuo
questo qui laggiù
non lo guardavano nemmeno
vabbè
fa lui
lasciamo perdere
ma intanto
pigliati un po' questo qui
in mancanza di meglio
e lei effettivamente
si è accontentata
e quella notte
sono stati bene insieme
però lui
ha fatto una stupidaggine
il giorno dopo
è andato a raccontarla
a tutti
e così l'ho sentita
anch'io
e ve l'ho raccontata
grazie
bene
e buonanotte a tutti
e all'anno prossimo
naturalmente
grazie